[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I said bound today
Ryan bound Michael Rosenberg making my
dad proud because I usually just say
rose and bomb bomb hey guys thanks for
uh listening to the podcast today got a
really good one and I I appreciate you
listen there's a lot of podcasts out
there and you chose this one as one of
your podcasts to listen to so I hope
you're having a great week
um if you want to subscribe that would
be great if you're here for Sophie bacon
and Kyle gallner gallner from uh smile
the hit movie smile that's out there
right now
subscribe write a review it really helps
the little podcast that could and um
write a review the handles are Ryan at
inside of you pod on Twitter inside of
you podcast on Instagram and Facebook
that is absolutely correct and uh you
can also go to the inside of you online
store for some great merch there's some
really cool merch out there autograph
scripts from Smallville and tumblers
from inside of you and also uh my
patreon patreon.com inside of you join
uh top tiers get uh shout outs they they
help the podcasts immensely I don't know
what I would do without them I say this
every episode
um but uh top tiers also get there's
different tiers right and the top tier
gets packages every few months letters
for me uh YouTube lives where I they can
ask me questions just tons of stuff go
to patreon.com inside of you and uh join
today and I'll send you a message I need
to send messages because it's been a few
weeks and I've been busy but I'm gonna
send those messages uh so thank you
um what else I got some uh cons coming
up and in November
um going to San Francisco then I go to
Columbus in Pittsburgh so be looking for
that Galaxy con I think just at the very
end of November into early December
three cons back to back to back so check
those out they'll be on my Instagram
soon enough come say hello meet me
um that's it I'm also on Cameo join that
and what else Ryan anything else
anything else going on hot happy
Halloween happy Halloween if you noticed
Ryan we're having you know we had Tom
Holland director of Fright Night in
child Supply we had Chris Sarandon from
Fright Night
um and Princess Bride we uh today we
have soci bacon and Kyle gallner from
smile horror movie so it's been a horror
movie month and I like that and uh this
movie smile I'm a big horror fan and
there's not many movies that scare me
there's not many movies that I find fun
um I watch tons of them smile was a
really good time smile is worth seeing I
will say that the acting's great the
story is great it's shot well there's
some good scares I recommend it highly I
got these two people on and we had a fun
conversation she was she was hilarious
she got the Jason the Michael Myers yeah
she got the mask on Michael Myers mask
on oh wait Jason Voorhees Jason Voorhees
mask on she's walking around in it I
hope that uh Jason kept that edit in
there
um but it was fun well she sat down
immediately and started playing guitar
some uh Carol King Carol King so far
away just out right out the gate came in
the room and started doing that I just
love it loved her energy and you have a
lot of guitar players in here sometimes
and they resist but yeah right she's fun
she's feisty she's adorable
um yeah really really liked her and I
love Kyle Kyle was awesome we love you
Kyle who's on Smallville with me
um he's done so much he's got some great
stuff to talk about we get into it
um so without further Ado let's just
let's just do it let's skin inside of
Kyle gallner and soci bacon it's my
point of view you're listening to inside
of you with Michael Rose
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
it would be so fine to see your face at
my door
but it doesn't help to know you're just
time away
long ago I reached for you and there you
were right holding you again could only
do me good
how I wish I could but you're so far
away
one more song about moving along the
highway can't see much of anything
that's blue
if I could only work this life out of my
way
I'd rather spend it
being close to you
but you're so far away
it doesn't okay yeah
it's really really low it's really low
off the coast I did it not off the cuff
with the good with the cords in front of
me I can't read music no but you want
some musical theater
what do you mean I went to musical
School Musical music you didn't well I
mean I went to like a summer program at
NYU where we were like but nothing I
didn't learn musical theater Theory or
anything really were you a good student
just cracking my Red Bull I gave her Red
Bull she me like she needs one cup
Kyle imagine if I needed a Red Bull I am
like the most and like
kinetically energetic what do you think
Kyle that do I think you need a red do
you think I have a lot of energy or do
you think I'm more like down
um I think you have a lot of energy I
think it's perfect it's not overwhelming
Kyle has a lot of energy and then he
said and then randomly later he'll be
like I was really sick the whole time
and I was exhausted and I wouldn't even
know I had Lyme disease no I know but
I'm saying wait a minute wait you had
Lyme disease Kyle I wouldn't have even
known because yeah when I went in for my
wardrobe fitting and my prep and are my
rehearsal and stuff like a couple days
before that I was like I'm starting to
feel not so good
and then I found that I had Lyme's
disease and then he just killed it every
single [ __ ] day were you excited I
was I was on antibiotics by the time and
Ritalin no I'm just kidding so you're
off it now you I mean you don't have
lime because I'm good I'm done I mean
because Lyme disease something that
could last a long time if you don't it's
like again it's like a gamble people
some people have it for like the rest of
their lives like a version of it it's
really weird it's it's a really really
weird weird disease thing you know
what's funny is I was told that I had
Lyme disease I was tired I was this I
was that and so my friends oh so she
just dropped the Red Bull all over the
place and well now it's dripping it's
okay just get a towel you're it's fine
okay
this is how it goes so the Lyme disease
they told me I you know I want you to
see my friend she's a doctor and you
know so they did all these tests they
have to do a certain test and they she
said you have Lyme disease and you eat
all this and I was like I don't know
so she started giving me these shots and
all this stuff and then I went to the
head guy at Cedars Caesar Cedars
Cedars infectious diseases and I told I
gave him the test results he goes
you don't have Lyme disease you just
like so she lied you just don't have it
it's like these tests could come
positive these tests that they do aren't
even accurate they think they're at it's
it's a big controversy over it but I
just listened to him because he went to
med school and all this stuff so I just
said you know screw it but uh anyway
back to you guys so listen you're just
really bored yeah well you know
you got your headphones okay so guys
as you can see in my room Kyle you can't
see it but I've got the Lost Boys poster
by the way Alex Alex winners coming in
after you guys Alex winner what yeah
Bill and Ted's and all that stuff he's
he's great he's a guy in the back hell
yeah he was the other guy
um fright night evil dead aliens the
thing I'm a big horror movie fan and
most horror movies
suck I mean I have watched I have spent
countless dollars with horror movie
Nights with my friends and we just we
watched them and we're like another six
bucks wasted yep six bucks 5.99 for a
rental whatever got it and so I have to
admit there you go yeah I'm like what
the [ __ ] I know well first of all I
didn't know you were in a Kyle and we'll
get to how we met in a minute there is a
five dollar Tuesdays in Glendale really
sorry yeah oh I didn't know that yeah
but I went to see smile and I didn't
know you were in it Kyle and
I wrote this down because I anyone who
listens to this podcast knows I'm a big
car or not
Yeah just they know it and I'm always
upset because Ryan you know there's just
not many good ones like I just said it
but this movie
was not only scared me at times but with
a lot of horror movies don't do is they
establish sort of a character and a
relationship and by the time the movie
is 10 minutes in you don't give a [ __ ]
usually but I cared about you and then I
I I began to slowly care about you as
because because you don't come in till I
mean you kind of like yeah come in and
then you're like oh oh [ __ ] I won't give
anything away you can give it away now
it's out spoiled no no people have to go
see this especially if you like horror
movies this worked this is one of the
few out there that works and is it the
number one movie out right now
um I think that Halloween beat it this
past weekend which fair I get it it's
been around you shouldn't get it because
I I honestly yeah I mean they're the
worst movies ever made right but you
know what I mean it's such a classic and
everybody wants to go and whatever but
it was number one everybody's two weeks
in a row
yeah we had a a
what do we call it when you binge on all
the movies a
um oh Marathon a marathon of all the
nightmare Elm Streets yeah all the
Friday 13th and all the Halloween
out of like 12 Halloweens
it was like maybe two that were pretty
good I know and it's like they keep
doing it and you're like but people just
it's Halloween you gotta go see
Halloween no you have to go you're a
genius yeah but also the I think so
Halloween is like the only franchise I
haven't watched because when I was a
little kid I was so afraid of it because
my brother tortured me with the mask so
I've never even seen the original really
yeah see that's a good one but I've seen
yeah I mean I need to probably go back
also your Napoleon Dynamite bobble head
that's what I spotted do you know he's
in my horror movie Nights what what do
you mean John heater he plays Nepal he's
one of my best friends yeah okay I I
love him he kind of talks like that
sometimes like what I'll I'll sit there
and go
jeez this movie's terrible
are you talking like me oh and I'll go
yeah he goes you're just jealous because
Lex Luthor doesn't have a distinct voice
oh my God that's so funny yo we've got
alpacas um
this year my parents got them and I was
like I feel like
my parents have alpacas yep rescue
alpacas which I didn't even know that
was a thing anyways moving on so why did
you like it like would it like did it
scare you I always want to know what
people you know what makes your skin
crawl at times you know that scene where
you're in the room and then all of a
sudden the girl's just standing there
smiling at you and then you know you
kind of like oh my God what's what's
happening and what she does next is
pretty it's just like the build like
there's a build there's not just a sound
that makes you go oh yeah I'm a jump
scare it was
it was sort of refreshing got it and you
went through a lot yeah with your
character I mean that those movies are
not easy to do or pull off and you got
to pull off that you're not crazy but
you're crazy right but you're not crazy
totally it's so hard I think it's
probably one of like
well Kyle do you think I probably think
that playing anxiety even though I'm
always anxious me too in life
is probably one of the hardest and I've
always felt that way like it's one of
the hardest acting things because it's
like I don't know why I can be sad or
happy or whatever but anxious is hard so
that so yeah it's tough it's tough do
you guys I'll ask you know do you trust
does it take you time to trust the
director because when you're being so
vulnerable You're like do I look like an
idiot doing this is this real is this or
do you just let go and they've learned
to just say hey I'm going to do my part
and he'll tell me if it's bad well I
think Kyle the thing that I loved about
Kyle like right off the bat which
clearly as like when you watch the movie
there's such a connection between us
there's such a chemistry and energy like
a real like we're playing ball you know
what I mean we have like a super you
know whatever
um and by the way everyone chemistry if
you don't get like it's not like you
need camp like you it's not like
chemistry off screen I mean we're
friends but I'm saying like what if one
person is a good actor and the other
person's not it won't look like there's
chemistry if you know if as long as both
people are good actors it will you know
and you're committed really committed
yes exactly and like and also we like
really got along like as friends but
anyways so I think what I loved about
Kyle is that I can tell he's the type of
actor I can tell that he is the type of
actor who has been working
long enough to under to know how to make
stuff and this has nothing to do with
smile but stuff that isn't written well
or difficult directors and still kill it
not that Parker was difficult not that
it wasn't written well just that those
types of actors are the ones that can do
anything you know what I mean so I came
in and so did Kyle I think as I call it
director proof as in no matter what the
director is doing you can do your job
and I think that it took me a little
while to lighten let up on that a little
bit and then once I did I unders like
Parker
had such a vision and was so specific
and was amazing it's just that I think I
was a bit um
I'm just I I don't trust any directors
at first maybe you don't trust people at
first well definitely well I also I also
think you know you come into a film like
this and
when you deal with
directors or or people who have such a
specific Vision there is this learning
curve where at the beginning you feel
like you're in a bit of a box because
it's like well you have to hit point A B
and C because this is how the camera is
working and we're not going to follow
you around and we're not going to do
these things you can't just be natural
there's such a specific way this movie
was shot that
I don't want to say you're at Mercy of
the camera and at Mercy of of the vision
but you kind of are because you're there
as you're there to tell this story and
have you know and to show this
director's vision and and that can get a
little that can get a little tricky
especially at the top just because
you're like oh
so I can't walk to this side of the room
I have to be right here it's like yeah
you have to be right here and with
Sophie you know what Cersei was saying
or has said before there's a lot of like
directly into the lens type of stuff
which automatically kind of puts you in
a strange a strange space
um Kyle is so I don't know if you came
in director proof as much as I think
it's just no I'm saying we are almost
like this are like a learning curve of
like what are we making I'm sorry I'm
more saying director proof as in if we
did have a terrible director
he wasn't at all he was great it's just
that yeah I know and but Kyle okay
he is the best at those things that are
awkward as an actor you know like
Exposition best person at Exposition
I've ever seen in my life I don't know
how he does it makes it sound natural
makes it sound interesting somehow
you're forgetting its Exposition if he
needed to look down the lens it wasn't
this whole like drama you know how like
acting is basically feeling like a
buffoon oh yeah doing a horror movie
like that you feel like a buffoon the
whole time because for me at least and
I'm more insecure about it like so I was
like I can't do it again you know what I
mean so did you think
did you think it was going to be a
success like this or are you just kind
of playing a park going hey all right
this guy's cool and got a vision and I
don't know if this is did you honestly
think I don't know if this is gonna work
I'm just doing it
Tyler it was never supposed to go to
theaters yeah no
no no we made this for Paramount Plus
for the tea for for TV it was nice
and they loved it so much that they put
it in theaters it tested so well that
they put it in theaters and by the way
that's only happened with one other
movie I've heard by the way Kyle I mean
we met because you did Smallville yeah
you were the Flash
and one came back to the other yes you
came back and uh we had some fun and you
know I always liked you was was acting
something you always wanted to do since
you were a young kid or had you get into
that yeah it wasn't anything that I
necessarily like thought about you know
it was never I was never one of those
kids who grew up being like this is my
dream I um I really just fell into it my
sisters were
um pursuing dance like you know ballet
and and all that stuff and um so our
family was more
on that route but because of that she
went to a performance arts Camp she went
to interlock and I think is in New York
and
um she got a little bit of an acting bug
because you had to do a theater
performance and so somebody point us in
the direction of a um like a talent
manager in Philadelphia
uh and we just all went and I ended up
like reading a commercial for them and
they sent me out to my first audition
that weirdly happened to be at an agency
and I had no idea what I was doing but
they asked me and my mom to stay and
then they asked if they if we had
representation and we didn't even know
what that meant so like I got all I got
an agent off of my first audition like
it was like this weird sort of snowball
thing and
then as I got older and started you know
watching movies and taking classes and
really pursuing it I just I I made the
decision
right before I turned 18 that this is
what I was going to do like I I had no
higher educational goals
I was sitting there I was like I don't
know what the [ __ ] I'm gonna do yeah you
know everybody's getting ready for
college I'm like I have like a 2-5 I'm
not getting dude I had a two
I felt like an old um uh report card not
long ago and I was like thank God I
didn't do anything that's not a smart
child yeah no man so I I ended up just
doing that and then
you know falling in love with it as it
went and really just decided to make a
go of it so it was pure dumb luck but
somebody said that you you followed your
sister to an audition yeah so she that's
the thing she went to that talent
manager in Philadelphia and we were just
there I'm one of four kids what does she
do now yeah what does your sister do now
uh real estate so when you so wait Kyle
when you like got on set for the first
time and stuff like to work how old were
you
14. and so like do you remember it was
it like whoa
or was it like what yeah it was it it
was kind of
like there's few there's there's a
handful of times in your life when you
get to walk into something that is just
so new and so different and that you
have no
I had no concept of what I was doing
other than I could say lines and make
them sound real when I was young and
that's you know I didn't have any skill
sets I hadn't gone to class I hadn't
really studied or learned anything I was
just a kid who could talk I guess and
they liked me for it
this show is sponsored by better Help
Therapy online
the amazingly talented people who appear
on my podcast and me let's be honest may
seem like we have it all figured out
but we obviously don't navigating any of
life's challenges can make you feel
unsure whether it's a career change a
new relationship or becoming a parent
unfortunately life doesn't come with a
user manual a trained therapist is the
next best thing therapists are trained
to help you figure out the cause of
challenging emotions and learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing to a guided
tour of the complex engine called you
as the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched 3 million people
with professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available a hundred percent
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief question there to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime it couldn't be any simpler no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist learn
more and save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash inside inside
here is brought to you by Geico Geico
asks how would you love a chance to save
some money on insurance well of course
you would after all who doesn't love a
great deal right and when it comes to
Great rates on insurance for all the
things in your life Geico can help like
with insurance for your car truck
motorcycle boat and RV even help with
homeowners condo or renter's coverage
you could save even more with a special
discount when you bundle your coverages
plus add the easy to use Geico mobile
app available 24-hour roadside
assistance and more and choosing to
switch to Geico becomes an Easy Choice
switch today and see all the ways you
could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
it just kind of happened it sounds like
this just kind of happened yeah it did
and then and actually like that I was
ever on where people really took me
under their wing was Smallville
uh wow I was really really taken care of
on that set and people showed me the
camera and showed me around people were
very very good to me on that so how old
were you not actually being there yeah
how was the first
man I was my mom was still with me so I
wasn't old enough to be there by myself
so I had to be 15 16. oh and I was 30.
and you were 30. oh my God it's my
little brother and so how were people
nice on The Closer just kidding I'm just
kidding Kyle
um yeah I worked with your mom on the
clothes okay so you he was 15 and you
were 30 and you were was it out here in
L.A no I was in Vancouver I think oh God
okay and did you so you went with your
mom and you stayed at like a hotel or an
apartment or something something Place
Hotel I didn't know they put kids there
it's a little you know well wait a
minute because Sophie and it's funny
because the first thing I think of when
I think of your name first of all I
thought it was sozy yeah like so she's
on a vacation far away how many times
have you heard that no never so she's on
a vacation far away
[Applause]
I don't know people don't really that's
I've never heard that before wow you are
original you're welcome
um really your parents didn't want you
to act no they really I mean I can
understand because they knew what
Hollywood was they'd seen the good
they've seen a lot of the bad yeah did
they really try to keep you away from it
no I think that's like a very it's a
story that's been like kind of like
telephone you know what I mean like one
article said it and then another one and
it's funny this person was asking me the
other day like so did what did they like
knock scripts out of your hand and I'm
like no it wasn't like they were that
against it they just didn't say either
way they wanted me to figure it out out
on my own
but that being said the reason I said
that when I was like 19 or whatever the
[ __ ] I said that is that
I saw I think and this is still true I
saw how like unglamorous and sort of
painful it can be to be an actor and I
therefore never I like idolized it or it
wasn't like this dreamy thing that I was
like working towards like I just want to
be a star and be on a movie like it
wasn't like that for me and I don't know
if that's an annoying thing to say but
that's just what's true I saw the bad
side of it as well well your parents I
mean Kyra Sedgwick and Kevin Bacon I
mean classic
but I mean Friday the 13th I mean Friday
the 13th the horror movie The Knife to
the chest remember yeah of course the
neck the neck the neck the great CG on
that one oh yeah great seat but they
seem I I don't know if I'm right but
they seem the most normal as as you can
be as a couple in Hollywood they have
withstood the test of time in a lot of
ways yeah and they've stayed together
right yeah I mean that happens yes they
have no no I'm not doing any reveals I
mean I don't know I don't have like a
metric for normal were you around
celebrities big celebrities your whole
life no no no they kept you waiting you
know like we just lived in New York so
like I grew up in the city in Manhattan
so like
for New York it's not cool to be an
actor right or a producer it's just not
like it's it's cool like it's not what
all the rich kids do parents do I'm like
you know what I'm saying out here it's
more of a thing so no I wasn't around
big celebrities ever I think I met
Howard Stern once and I was like oh my
God because we listened to Howard Stern
from when I was like four years old in
the house like I remember
so inappropriate like we it was always
on so I thought he was cool but I I
didn't know I did not it wasn't like
that really it wasn't like what like
maybe Willow Willow Smith's what life is
probably like you know what I mean like
those kids are real likes like their
their parents are celebrities and have
kind of chosen to live that put them out
there yeah but like with us we didn't no
I don't
were you like once you're old enough did
you start going I'm gonna watch
everything they've done I got to see my
parents and everything no I'm not a
[ __ ] loser
no I I am I have not maybe I'll do that
tonight a marathon no a marathon I
didn't watch it when I was younger
because honestly weirdly like I tried to
watch I watched Balto
which is a animated movie
yes it's a it's but he voices the
[ __ ] Balto my dad I didn't see both
it's called Balto yeah you need to watch
that no I'm kidding it's just like a
Disney movie that like nobody's seen But
I watched that because my dad was like
you should watch at least one movie when
I was a kid and it upset me so much when
like anyone was mean to the animated dog
that was like his voice it wasn't even
so from then on I just didn't I haven't
watched them I want to watch serve
Echoes because it's that similar to this
is dark yeah it's a good one but that's
like kind of the same it's just him the
whole time blah blah I think so it's
been a long time since I've seen it got
it but then I like that yeah that's but
yeah you seem pretty normal I mean I
didn't it's funny because I just watched
the movie and I was just like oh my God
I gotta get caught on the podcast and I
go and I gotta get this girl she's great
because I didn't know you I mean
um and then I looked looked you up and I
go oh my gosh look at that that's the
daughter of so and so too dude she's
super talented that's a good thing then
yeah I had no idea but Kyle am I normal
Kyle she know be honest be honest I
don't know if an actor neither of us
yeah I was gonna say there's like a
sliding scale of normal I wouldn't
consider myself particularly no he's not
he's not normal at all
neither of us are normal I will say that
you have you grow a tremendous mustache
thank you yes it's unbelievable how I
can't grow anywhere else look at me this
takes whatever just disgusting no but
this is this for real this is it it's
like musketeer time all the time there's
never anything here nothing here it's
only a mustache the camera loves Kyle's
face like you know people who's just
like their faces just work on camera
yeah Kyle it does your face works too
obviously I mean yeah sure but I'm maybe
but I'm I it's hard for me to be it's
hard for me to be like objective about
my own stupid face but Kyle's yeah
Kyle's for sure were you do you guys
ever deal with because I talk to other
actors about this do you deal with
anxiety do you deal with not only
anxiety but you deal it when you're
working when you're like when you get
first get a role or the nerves going
you're like I want to be great you've
got to be great [ __ ] yeah of course we
all do Matthew McConaughey was just
talking about you feel like you're gonna
get fired I mean what goes through your
mind table reads table reads are the
worst you think I've never been fired
from a table read but my friend John
heater
twice
twice
sad also I did a pilot want to know this
yeah I did a pilot for sci-fi The
Magicians pilot six months I waited to
hear if it got picked up fired
and the show went they didn't tell you
maybe they didn't know I don't know you
look like you're missing an arm sorry
I'm so weird physically
what about you Kyle do you get do you
get anxiety or you get nervous or you
get yeah I think I think the day you
don't get nervous is the day you don't
care and I think that's a problem you
know what I mean I think I think you
should always be a little
within reason you know if it's like
crippling I mean I you know from one set
to the other I'm sure things are going
to be more nerve-wracking but yeah I
still get nervous I get anxious I still
get excited that first day you're gonna
walk on and
you know especially like what you're
talking about that weird earlier like
that weird thing of like say you do get
just an offer and you have a [ __ ]
idea that's left of center and you show
up that first day and nobody's ever seen
you do it that's really that's
everyone's pretty nerve-wracking yeah or
you can't get the lines out you just
keep stumbling and it's in your head I'm
sorry guys [ __ ] yeah I I dream all the
time I never say sorry though I don't
ever want to be that vulnerable to them
I just want to I'm I'm angry but I don't
get angry with them I guess it's called
straight white male privilege no I'm
just kidding no no I just go not not
saying sorry no no it's not that I'm I'm
not yelling at it I'm at myself I'm like
come on what the [ __ ] I'm just joking
because we always say sorry what the
[ __ ] the line I'm sorry I do say I'm
sorry you do oh God wait so Kyle I have
a question for you real quick did you
feel like this this part was like a
challenge for you
because that didn't seem like it
you know I think every part of the chat
to me the challenge and the thing that I
wanted to accomplish was what me and you
were on the same page with when we
stepped in there it was like we have a
small window to establish these two and
their past and what they've been through
and that will allow us to make the
interesting choices we want to make
further down the road so that to me was
sort of
my
my kind of not fear going in but the
thing that I really wanted to make sure
you know that I was most nervous about
is you know because I didn't know you we
hadn't met yet I didn't know how you
wanted to operate and then when we got
there and and we spoke and we rehearsed
you know we were both very much on the
scene incredibly disappointed of how do
we how do we how do we make these two
you know and establish the relationship
because
the other thing that me and soci wanted
to accomplish was we wanted to at least
try to find a little bit of humor in
something that was so [ __ ] dark dark
and I think two people who know each
other and each other's [ __ ] so well
going through a situation like this I
think can be kind of naturally sort of
funny you know what I think uh it was
unique in the way that you seem like a
secondary character right off the bat
you seem like oh
you know it's the ax okay I'm like oh
Kyle he has a nice scene in the movie
that's great and you know I love Kyle
yeah dinner in America was wonderful he
was freaking amazing and that you guys
have to go see dinner America I I've
tweeted about it whatever it's great
like Napoleon Dynamite an acid yeah um
it's on Hulu right now Hulu and also I
gotta see Charlie says oh I mean okay
Matt Smith yeah I don't know it's a good
movie actually yeah it actually I love
that stuff it's a weird scary [ __ ]
movie but go ahead it's about Charles
Manson right yeah Patricia
um kenwinkle she's one of the ones
convicted yep of doing the murders yes
you have that mischievous kind of look
do I really I have a little bit of a
cultivally with long dark hair yeah you
do have a little cultivation culty
aesthetic yeah when said they put like
long brown extensions in I was like okay
colty anyways go on sorry
um oh so what I like is that this
character and you have to be likable
right off the bat have to sort of like
you're like oh all right all right and
it's funny how her own is it your fiance
or your fiance doesn't really believe
her and he's just not supportive and
it's just like he's trying to so you
understand where he's coming from like
like I would think that to him like oh
my gosh I'm with a woman who's out of
her mind I don't know what to do and he
gives up on her right and she has no
place to go other than to you and I
thought that was a really cool little
twist there and it worked and it kind of
propelled the movie and you were with
you guys and and me and Kyle are
actually that codependent
is that it no no but no but but like do
you know the people that like like Kyle
and I are both the type of people that
would be like if I called him and I was
like look
got to bury a body like you know what I
mean you just don't want to watch no I'm
just saying nothing says team building
like getting rid of a bot no but you
know how like the character of Trevor my
fiance he's got like boundaries and like
a life plan and stuff Kyle and I I think
like in the movie and in real life are
kind of like I don't know what do you
think Kyle I mean save me it sounds like
I'm crazy when I'm saying this
no I I think there's you know I again
like
JT you know playing playing that fiance
role I think that's that's more of a
logical
um
place you know I think more people would
Veer that way than the way that Joel
went but I'm much more of a Joel in real
life anyway like if somebody comes to me
and says some crazy [ __ ] I'm like
whatever like let's go
I need to move in with you and your wife
in Vermont and your kids he would be
like okay like would you really say Okay
100 if what tell me if she wanted to
move in with you and your wife for a
while and their kids
no no there's no way she wouldn't you'd
have to ask your wife and she said what
are you talking about
I'd have to ask my wife but I honestly
think my wife would say yeah I know that
he would it like I would say yes I live
alone I love okay that's fine I love
this house it's sick thank you it is I
like this house it is it is fun can I
try this on you can totally do you want
to try it on really yeah take it off
she's gonna put the it's it's Halloween
this is airing uh pretty much on
Halloween okay see you then so go ahead
and put the Friday the 13th mask I want
to come over oh there you go
hang on a second hang on did you were
you guys rebellious growing up in terms
of like you could see how
um yeah look for me my parents are so
I've talked about my dysfunction you
know I no one really listened to me in
fact my brother
call me one morning and he says
he says I had these nightmares about our
family and then I wrote down things that
I remembered and I go oh okay and he
started reading them to me and he goes
and then when I got to you when I
started writing about you all I remember
is
and then there was Michael
nobody ever listened to him or paid any
attention to him oh my God and I was on
the phone and honestly a tear came down
my eye and I and I I was sucking it up
and I was like and what made me sad was
the fact that someone acknowledged it
like your knowledge the [ __ ] that I
someone it was it was crazy so what are
you a middle a middle okay that's that's
tough and then also what's your sign
Cancer
what are you Pisces oh we get along my
of course we're water my dad and my
brother are cancer and so I think that's
hard that's really really hard I'm sorry
but were you yeah but what I was
thinking was you know I was I wasn't a
bad kid I got into some trouble I had
that teenage angst and whatever did you
guys I'll start with Kyle did you have
any of that going on or like I'm an
actor now I'm gonna drink I'm gonna
pound on my nose Justin Bieber I didn't
start drinking because I was an actor
but no I uh I yeah I mean I
I started drinking at 14 me and my
friends are like you know
Punk and hardcore listening skate rats
that would steal alcohol from people's
garages over the weekend and
um you know run around the golf course
and throw the flags into the water
hazards at night and like weird [ __ ]
like that we were
we were just like Suburban bad boys we
were just like looking for trouble all
the time you know what I mean we were
always kind of pushing back and mayor
duels
you know I my parents are great like it
wasn't one of those those things it it
just was like we were just always
in trouble kind of in one way or or
another we would just we're always sort
of looking for trouble I don't I don't I
don't know but with your parents were
you sort of like rebellious with your
parents and like because I have some
friends in Indiana and I grew up in a
weird little town let me tell you I I'm
not I pretty much love everyone I've
ever met from Indiana which is random
well I mean there's a lot of people I
know from my neighborhood who are in
prison or went to prison there's one one
for murder that my mom only let one
person spend the night at my house his
name was Tom Wagner murdered the
murderer killing someone and I was like
good judge a character mom uh no they
have the worst judge parents crazy and
but I remember Rebellion against them no
but so were you like that with your
parents because I have friends in this
neighborhood I definitely gave my
parents a hard time there's definitely a
window where we were like constantly
butting heads and at odds and I I you
know I think a lot of that was growing
pains and puberty and
you know I have
I have others like I was Tiny in school
too and and I
was dealing with like my own [ __ ] a
little bit where like I have like I'm
dying I have like I'm like OCD 80d ADHD
and Tourette's so I was always like oh
wow Ticky and like if you'll watch this
back you'll see me make face I I think I
do that too don't you think Ryan I'm
Ticky no not that I've seen yeah thanks
you're a little bit I've I've noticed a
little bit have you but yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah but it's like move around
stuff it used to be all right like like
like like like like like like like like
voice that's hard where people like
judging you and making fun of you
um sometimes a little bit but it was
also like it just was exhausting on me
like where on me and like little things
that I didn't even know how to
put out where like suddenly I would
develop a reading tick where like it
would be if I didn't say the sentence
perfectly in my head I would have to
start over so like two pages of a of a
assignment in class would take me over
an hour to read because I couldn't get
it right so like things were frustrating
were people aware of it that they help
you were people patient with you did you
take medications my parents were you
know it was more I was more the
generation it was that generation where
they just [ __ ] medicated everything
oh yes oh my God yeah they're just like
absolutely medicated
I would take pills and I'd fall asleep
and like in the middle of class and like
weird [ __ ] like that and finally I had a
certain age where I just was like I'm
done taking this [ __ ] I'm just gonna
deal with it and then I started acting
and acting actually really helped a lot
with all of that to cool it all off
so it was like a combination of things I
was dealing with my own [ __ ] and I was
always kind of pushing back we were
always in trouble me and my parents had
Growing Pains but like
you know
I was never like super I'm sure my well
that's not true my dad at one point
looked at me you know I'm not logging
but I was like there's like nine years
but I just didn't really like you
well deserved but we get along really
well now like me and my folks get along
really well and I'm tight with my
siblings and
you know it's I don't know it's like
just teenage angst I guess but probably
a little more elevated I never like
tipped into drugs but I was getting
really [ __ ] up and drunk and all that
[ __ ] for like a long time right so see
what about you going up
um definitely tipped into drugs I'll
tell you that no but I was I was a bad
kid but it was like my family's super
close by the way I just want to say very
very close family my brother's like my
best friend
um we're all we all love spending time
together always have it's just that
I was bad well I grew up in Manhattan so
there was just a lot of drugs and a lot
of alcohol you say drugs you're just
talking pot or maybe cocaine oh no like
yeah drugs pills like yeah oh yeah like
I won't get into all of them but all of
them
um and so because it's New York City you
know um and I mean my parents were super
like strict about money so
so like but all of my other friends had
like endless money you know what I mean
my parents give me like 15 a week in
Manhattan as my allowance no a month a
month 15 a month as my Manhattan
allowance so what I because they were
like it's not your money it's our money
you know what I mean they it was great
but
um my friends all had like Limitless you
know so anyways we did a lot but I kept
it secret from them which I think was
another kind of hard like for them did
they ever find out of course like
they've found out over the years and
I've told them and all that but like yes
little things would happen I think it
was just it's almost worse I think
probably for a parent that they're
keeping it a secret
um so I feel bad about that for sure
because I think I really scared them for
a while but now you know it like
everything me too yeah he goes out and
watch but
um I was going to say something about
Kyle I was going to say diverting the
attention no I'm not what I noticed I
just what I noticed about being on set
with you Kyle is that like you would
have tics and stuff but like once in a
while but never while you were in a take
that's literally what I mean like the
thing that really helped me get it under
control was acting because I couldn't
like you just weren't allowed yeah but
it's almost like you can shift
like
my mental state would have to shift or I
wouldn't be myself for whatever so for
those two three minutes at a time I
didn't have to be me and it would like
turn off that's awesome I don't know how
that goes wow it was very weird and and
it really helped me get a grip on it and
then you know age helped me just come to
terms with the fact that it's like just
you're just gonna [ __ ] be all over
the place a little bit just let it
happen we all are have you guys ever
seen your parents cry because I've never
seen my dad cry or show emotion wow oh
and told my half-sister passed away two
years ago and that's the first time I
heard him on the phone but holy [ __ ] was
it weird and scary it was just
devastating never in my life seen any
kind of emotion except anger and just
distance you know sort of and then
hearing that it it did break my heart it
was just a complete shock doesn't it
make you feel bad for him a bit that he
could never show emotion like before
that just old school sort of mentality
yeah yeah I was like gosh it must be
hard yeah what about you Kyle did you
ever see your parents cry yeah I've seen
both of them cry I've seen my mom cry a
few times and I I remember the first
time seeing my dad cry and being like
whoa yeah like it really it really took
me
took me back not not to say you know my
mom's feelings aren't as important it
just it was more it was really jarring
to see my dad like lose it and then it
was like years and years and years later
before
I really saw I didn't even see it I
heard it he called me to tell me his
brother passed away
and that was like
I mean I got I hung up the phone and
just I lost it hearing him upset made me
so upset
like it was it's hard that's how I felt
when he was sitting there crying he was
like you know he's just hysterical and I
remember just going I go I go Dad I'm
with you I'm here you know I understand
I you know it's like you just how do you
deal have you have you seen your dad cry
my parents are actors so they cry all
the time
[Music]
my dad no not as much like he gets
choked up a lot but I think he's a
cancer yeah he's sensitive but no I I
don't I actually don't think I've ever
seen him heard him seen him break down
like that just choke up yeah really yeah
no do you want to see it
so bad no I really didn't know I
honestly really really don't like me and
my will break your heart no no of course
I would want him to feel comfortable too
right but me and my dad are so connected
we're like so similarly
sensitive empathetic like to the point
where our like
we just like uh I know what he feels and
he knows what I do what I feel and I cry
all the time do you cry all the time oh
my God yeah and so when I think about
how much you know like real sadness he
has probably because I have a lot of it
because we're so similar I'm like man I
don't know does that make sense like
yeah it does I want if I saw him cry
like that it would be really hard for me
but I but he's welcome to obviously
dad you're welcome
anytime he gets choked up though this is
your invite yeah I get choked up by the
way I know you guys just did a horror
movie and I guess Charlie says is also
sort of A Hard movie right you've done
some dark [ __ ] mostly dark mostly dark
[ __ ] Kyle you've done a ton of horror
movies I mean dude haunting of
Connecticut Jennifer's Body Nightmare on
Elm Street screen like my favorites of
my era that I went to to the movies and
songs screw you're a scream King
yes I'll take it man you know it's a
cool thing by the way Jennifer's Body
who is in that Megan Fox Megan Fox how
was it working with Megan Fox
um it was good you know it was it was
there was a part of it that like my
heart kind of broke for her every day
because it was smack in
Megan Fox pandemonium with everybody was
just like
so all over her that you could tell she
was like so guarded guarded in it and it
sucked because she was being sort of
just like objectified as a person by
everybody all by the world that it it
that was hard but she was very nice to
me
um
I had a good time working with her
um I actually had a really good time on
that movie
where you want to talk about showing up
and
I mean I I read for uh Johnny Simmons
role to be the boyfriend and I didn't
get it so they just offered me Colin and
I just showed up and did the voice with
all that weird [ __ ] and they had never
seen it what did they say and I I did
that first take and Karen came up to me
and she was just like
um
just do it again I was like oh [ __ ]
like it was it was pretty trippy but no
man Megan was Megan was great I I
enjoyed working with her and I'm really
happy to see that that movie is actually
kind of getting a second
life yeah absolutely it was such a great
movie yeah did you guys see the
Woodstock 99 dock yes so can you believe
that's how 99 like that's when I was
like um don't say eight or something I
was born in 92 so seven but that's how
people treated women like just that
recently it was horrible it was awful
it's like they were just for the taking
it is horrible and some of those bands
just when you watch it just piss me off
how they got it going I know it was it
was hard to watch well yeah but just I
mean I'm thinking about how when did you
shoot that movie Kyle oh boy I that was
years ago early like early I did that
right after haunting Connecticut and I
turned 21 on the holiday in Connecticut
so I was probably 20.
22. but like what year I don't know what
was that never mind I found it a little
Ferry but I'm guessing 04
2009 okay still bad I mean I don't think
that like like you know what I mean that
era was just so women were so
objectified in like like an almost
insane way like there was no decorum
about it it was just like grab titties
and you know what I mean so anyways I
can imagine this unfortunately yeah
um what do you guys think of horror
movies do you like doing them after
doing a movie like smile after all the
movies you've done Kyle is it something
you're like I would like to do another
horror movie I would like to or is it
something you're like okay I did that
I'd like to move on now Kyle I'm not
gonna spoil anything but if there's a
sequel to this one of you I won't say
who or or so see one of you could be in
it maybe both I won't say anything but
sure would you do a sequel or would you
do another horror movie Kyle and I are
doing a buddy comedy wherein we are exes
trying to solve a crime
is this true we want it we want it yeah
we're trying to find a writer yeah we
want to get someone to write it on spec
but anyways
um I I love horror movies and I love the
genre I love watching them and I liked
be I loved like being in one whatever I
think it's just that that genre it
includes so many like I would say you
could have a horror movie that's a
straight comedy with Gore you know I
mean and people would say it's horror so
I think it kind of encompasses all
genres if that makes sense like Shawn of
the dead or you know what I mean yeah so
of course I would do another one but I'm
not gonna like exclusively seek out
horror movies I'll seek out you know
like as you know good characters and
great writing and whatever so I don't
know I don't set it apart so much I
guess right because I'm just saying that
after doing a movie like this you might
have a lot of horror directors going oh
oh I think I need to wait a little bit I
think I need to wait a little bit if
that's what you're asking yeah yeah a
little bit just do something a little
different next yeah Kyle yeah I mean I
think the nice thing is
I think the stigma for an actor being in
horror has been obliterated I think you
okay absolutely 10 years 10 years ago it
was a different thing you know like when
we made Nightmare on Elm Street or
Jennifer's Body or haunted Connecticut
it was like hey good for you you're in a
movie it it didn't matter how much it
made or whatever
um
you just weren't taken as seriously as
like yeah now you could do TV you could
do movies you could do it down
I mean people are now exploding I mean
look at Anya Taylor Joy off of the witch
you know what I mean like she's now
[ __ ] that's so true like even your
career Kyle is a testament to how like
it doesn't really matter because you can
do cool Indies and no one's like he's
the horror guy no one notices you unless
you do something that's good or
something that people like or is making
them yeah so that's what they look at
your Commodities the rest of it just
yeah yeah yeah
you know unless it's like a box office
flop or something but like that was that
was the craziest thing to me like
thinking about smile how well it's doing
and then thinking about my career over
the last [ __ ] 20 years and it's like
man I have not had
like the odds of getting in a movie in
the theaters that captures like
lightning in a bottle does really well
especially now without being slapped
into us into spandex into a superhero
suit is like almost impossible it never
happened and horror is one of the only
genres that delivers outside of that
so I mean I would absolutely do another
hard film again I you know I've done
enough of them to the point that
it definitely has to be something very
cool or special or something that I
think could be really cool
um you know I'm not just gonna jump on
to another one but
I'm not as cautious about doing another
one as I used to be you know five six
seven years ago because again that
stigma has been
kind of obliterated because I had a
horror movie that I wrote called deep in
the woods to read it are you being
serious I do but it's like but that's
good are we exercising and it's like is
it matters is it good that's the deal
with witchcraft and like I am a witch
tarot card reader cool are you yeah you
retards you want me to do yours
let me see if you have them oh I don't
know I I might I don't know by the way
what was it like I have to ask because
I'm watching House of dragon what was
Matt Smith like he was like method so he
didn't really talk to you very much not
really not really well I mean yeah was
he nice enough you know he was nice but
it was he was just Charles Manson so
he was meant
um like you know what I mean he was
really like in the character and the
character is um like gregarious and
charismatic and talkative and crazy and
that so it's not so in between takes he
was kind of quiet because I'm sure it
was exhausting he did a [ __ ] amazing
Charles Manson you gotta watch it Matt
Smith is an incredible actor I think
like seriously I think it's amazing and
I think for them to cast him as Charles
Manson was a bit of like a surprising
Choice it's not like the first person
you'd think of but he did such a good
job with the voice and the guitar
playing and the singing yeah I think
it's a it's kind of an interesting movie
you know it's done by the women who did
American Psycho America oh wow yeah yeah
yeah so it's like it's it's an
interesting movie and we shot it at a
place that looked
I mean it was in Santa Clarita but it
looked identical to the ranch so it was
very creepy and we used like real rotten
food like there was nothing real
cigarettes there was nothing like fake
about it wow I read to be Charles Manson
did you you did for that one yeah yeah
it did not go well what I don't think
that's the one for you
I I uh only got that part because
um someone dropped out so I found out
about it the day before the table read
and I was like [ __ ] dude
yeah did he improvise at all Matt yeah
yeah was he like kind of like a
dangerous thing were you enamored by it
or you're like holy [ __ ] this guy's like
on fire it was amazing it was wonderful
like it he um okay so I'm not good at
improvising it makes me feel like
uncomfortable and scared especially when
I have to like monologue you know what I
mean but he monologued like like but
like in what Charles Manson would say
yeah man yeah we're gonna do this man
yes exactly yeah yeah and you know who
else was really good in that movie is
Chase Crawford he was great
um and it was wild experience Charlie
says you gotta what's what's going on
next what are you guys looking to do
take a break or is there something in
the works what's going on Kyle
um
I you know right now I'm looking to just
chill at home for a little bit it's
getting harder for me to be away with my
kids they don't like it as much anymore
yeah
um so I'm being a little pickier it
would be nice to pick something up you
know maybe sometime early next year but
we'll see what happens
um and then I have a movie that I wrote
that we are currently
pushing forward there's actually like
finally maybe a little bit of
momentum movement and things happening
um
which would be very very cool uh so
we're you know we're really I'm really
focusing on that
um you know I've like three movies
that'll come out and sprinkle throughout
the next
year or so
okay
but uh you know I'm just kind of hanging
out we're buckling down getting ready
for winter time out here so oh yeah
that's yeah
but can we shoot your Woods movie where
Kyle lives so he doesn't have to leave
his kids sure maybe we'll do that by the
way you did you went to Brown University
and you studied musical theater it says
that in Wikipedia is wrong I went to
Brown University for a year and a half
did so many drugs that I dropped out and
I did one play and there was no songs in
it but Wikipedia good for example is
right
um what's next for you anything
um I don't want to take a break exactly
because I haven't worked since I did a
four or five days on a movie since smile
so I haven't worked basically at all I
would love to work
um but I do think that now I have to be
like a bit more choosy I did a movie in
Kentucky which I think is going to turn
out be really cool I'm directing a short
around the holidays that I wrote
and
um you know just kind of like
I do a bunch of other stuff but I like I
want to get a job but but it has to be
like a good one you know I have to
really like it I'm transitioning from
taking every single thing that anyone
would allow me to do to like being more
choosy that's weird yeah that's good all
right this is called [ __ ] talking with
Kyle gallner and so we're good at that
this is rapid fire these are from my
patrons they're amazing the top tier
patrons get to ask questions go to
patreon.com inside of you and join and
thanks for all the support without you
you know I couldn't do it so here we go
favorite song Raj favorite song movie
and TV show during 2022.
Raj so see go what'd you say favorite
song okay movie and TV show TV show
favorite TV show probably the staircase
that's aft fave favorite song Oh I like
this uh Bella white this song
just like leaving what's the next one uh
movie movie
um oh my gosh that's so hard I don't
know oh I like to come on come on I
really like come on come on even though
I know that that my boyfriend's in it
it's not the reason Kyle yeah I have no
[ __ ] idea I like I have kids I don't
watch anything me neither Kyle I like
caught up on like Kira Sawa stuff this
year that was like what I did oh wow
I don't think I watched a single movie
from this year this year okay well
moving on a smile I'm a garbage person
for this question you're going to have
to move past okay Leanne question for
both what is your all-time favorite
horror movie what is Lee olien which is
a person I'm so sorry all-time favorite
horror movie
um
Kyle at the Ring The Ring first first
like theater thing I got a couple that
I'm tied for I love 28 Days Later I love
Alien I love uh the thing
uh
uh Jaws is one of my favorite horror
movies of all time okay so you're just
going around the posters and yeah I love
The Descent you know I got a couple I
got I got a handful of them I'm pretty
big on all right I like it so see oh you
already said I'm ready three I'm not
someone who has favorites I don't know
mine is really The Shining but I also
love the shine too it's more like the
ring was like the one that I saw in the
theater horror like jump scare you know
it was really good too it holds up what
Blair Witch Project Blair Witch do you
know that we got um that tape
non-descript VHS in the mail it was and
I watched it by myself I almost [ __ ]
myself oh my God and we were in like in
at our farm and like my dad was like I
just got this he was like shaking like I
just got this movie I don't know what
you got it too yeah I wonder how many
people got it like is it like well my ex
girls never had it at her apartment and
she was sleeping and I go I'm gonna put
this movie in and she just fell asleep
immediately and I sat there going
is this real no that one is amazing it
was the first thing
dude it's it's amazing okay I love when
the close-ups on her face because oh
yeah yeah
uh Brett G what's your favorite memory
of Wes Craven I worked with him too my
favorite memory of Wes was
um
foreign
just the first time when I auditioned
for him for uh for red eye like a long
time ago he was just a very very when
you tell your kids to shut up hey guys
uh Michael needs to tell you something
shut your yappers
no I'll get it I'll get it I'll get it
um that and then I actually read for him
I actually auditioned for him again
and it was I forget what movie it was
for but my reps had sent me the script
and I wasn't supposed to have it and I
knew all this information and I started
talking to him about the character
and they actually
pulled me into the back of their office
and made me open my email and watched me
delete it oh my god wow that's after my
audition you can go back in your in the
folder and get anyway yeah yeah Nathan
Jay did you look at people differently
who smiled at you after making this
movie and also I'm gonna ask you
so see how hard was it to get that
perfect smile uh mine yeah I didn't do a
good smile
I didn't do a good song disagree I'll
tell you later but did I look at people
differently no I did not after shooting
it no after seeing it yes
shooting it was just kind of like a part
of all the other things if that makes
sense all right yeah fair enough Jeremy
C what was it like growing up oh we
already talked about Jeremy she wants to
know what was it like growing up with
iconic parents you didn't see them as
literally iconic every minute of it I'm
just kidding
okay next little Lisa what makes you
smile everything everything that Kyle
makes me smile everything what do you
mean like dogs animals good answers for
kids
Kyle you know what we just started
trying putting them in a room with two
chairs facing each other and letting
them work it out on their own are you
serious dead seriously does it work no
the room gets destroyed but like then
it's over oh my God that would never
work with mine they would they'd be a
bloodbath fist the Cuffs that's amazing
that you do that yeah it's not like it
goes well but at least it goes where
we're not like I don't know litigating
it uh this has been a real treat for me
me too it really lost really really fun
like so much fun yeah you guys are great
you guys are great together I could see
why you had so much fun doing this and
the chemistry even though you can't see
each other right now I can just see it
in my mind you can imagine we talk on
the phone all the time so this is normal
all right you know that's it I don't
really have anything else I loved uh
being inside of both of you today yeah
the show's called inside this is a real
treat guys go see smile you know I don't
like a lot of horror movies this is so
fun it's scary it's a great date movie
see it while it's in theaters and you
know when it's going to be streaming you
don't know yet no we don't know no no
yeah you guys got to see it I saw it in
the theater
you can see in the theater though it's
like the sound is really important it's
really good it's really good thanks for
having us this was really fun yeah I'll
see you guys later see you Kyle
[Music]
uh love that interview I really loved it
I love talking horror I love talking
um you know it's cool I I again I didn't
know that it was Kevin Bacon and uh Kyra
sedgwick's daughter no they just she's
she sure looks like it yeah she you look
at her wow yeah I could see that but she
looks more like Kyra Sedgwick I think
yeah but I thought she did phenomenal
job and smile really good job Sosi I
hope you come back she lives kind of
close her and her boyfriend yeah they
live close to me so but yeah she's
Paving her own way and so absolutely
Paving her own way and it's kind of a
good thing though you didn't notice I
had no idea no I didn't put it together
and then I looked around like oh yeah oh
that's cool yeah I wonder if she'll do
it and then I asked Kyle and Kyle got
her on so thank you Kyle Kyle wonderful
guest thank you for listening again join
patreon.com inside of you if you want to
join patreon be a patron and support the
podcast we could really use your help
and also don't forget to listen to talk
Ville every Wednesday that's tomorrow
and Ryan and I will be here with Tom
Welling talking about another Smallville
episode that we'll review and hopefully
we'll hear messages from you and uh
thank you for all the patrons for uh
become your patron of that and helping
the podcast out I'm going to give the
shout outs now
um so here we go why don't we do this if
you want to hear the intro you can I you
know I give you links and stuff to all
sorts of [ __ ] but we don't need to
repeat that uh thanks for listening to
the podcast shout outs Nancy D Leah s
Sarah V little Lisa you Kiko Jill e
Brian H Nico P Robert B Jason W Sophie M
Kristen K Raj C Joshua D Jennifer and
Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B Kimberly e
Mike e l Don Supremo
99 more correct Santiago M Chad
d w correct Leanne
Janine or Maya Maddie Belinda and Chris
R H Dave h Sheila Brad d Ray H Tabitha
Tom and Liliana Talia
forget
w m m Betsy D Chad d l
merrion Dan and big Stevie W Angel
amrianne and C Cory K devnex and
Michelle a Jeremy C Andy T Gavin hater
David C John B Brandy D Camille asked
Joey M Eugene and Leah Nico G Corey
Patricia Heather L Jake B Megan T Mel s
Orlando C
Caroline R Christine s Sarah s Eric H
Shane R Emma r
uh Jeremy V Andrew M did we say Kristen
K Christa Kia I love you so if we forgot
your name ever don't kill me I love you
Kristen
uh zatoichi 77 Oracle Chris R
uh Karina and Michelle D Amanda aramanda
s Jan B Kevin e Stephanie K Lina 82
Joelle and Billy s
uh again guys thank you for continuing
to support the podcast you really uh are
amazing and I appreciate that and I hope
you enjoyed today's podcast we've got
many more good ones coming up some good
guests that I I've been working on and
uh thanks for all the support and love
spread the word
um get more listeners and uh I guess
that's about it
from uh myself Michael rosemom in the
Hollywood Hills of California
he's taking a class right now and
writing scripts I know I love it he
loves it three hours holy [ __ ] we'll
wave to the camera hey guys uh I love
you be good to yourselves and please
come back and see us next week
um all right thanks for allowing me to
be inside of each and every one of you
we'll see you next time